you said that you talked to
busy's mom called you this one what's
your relationship with his mom and she
loved him and she loved me
we're moving on my eyes all week right
about the booster bags because i tell
them i'm gonna be able to make it oh
you're not going i'm going oh at first i
i wouldn't be able to make it because i
had a show
in texas but he was on your head about
it
hd you know it needs me i read it to me
he was i ran into him and he used to
i think friday thursday
and i kind of skipped i slipped through
the creation and i knew this was about
it and he called me back hey that's a
crazy lineup he's got oh he's crazy
little baby the baby uh
moose
i mean it's a wild lineup it's crazy
it's just like it was like it's like a
three-day thing though i mean it makes
sense for you to be honest
yeah you know that's my city so we got
it we got to figure it out to where i
can be there
and still make it to texas
but then this one this morning when i
was in the hotel his mama called me
but you know what i'm calling you for
like no what you gotta do for us he was
like i need you to come to the school
friday ready for the boosie beds the
kids want to see you so i like i'm gonna
make it happen that's crazy how's how's
so you've known have you known like
lucy's family yeah i've been we've been
locked in that's just wild to have like
yo his mom called me yeah
we've been locked in for 10 plus years